it is our honor and an absolute
privilege to be able to welcome the
class day speaker for the class of 2015
the Vice President of the United States
Joe Biden
hello you
great to see you all
thank you very very much thank you very
very much i Jeremy Kiki a hunter class
of 2015 congratulations and thank you
for inviting me to be part of this
special day you're talented you've
worked hard
and you've earned this day mr. president
faculty staff it's an honor to be here
with all of you my wife teaches
full-time I want you to know that at a
community college and is attended 8640
commencements and I endure the similar
versions of class today and I know they
can hardly wait for the speaker to
finish but I'll do my best as quickly as
I can to the parents grandparents
siblings family members the class of
2015 congratulations I know how proud
you must be
but the class of 2015 before I speak to
you please stand and applaud the ones
who loved you no matter what you're
wearing on your head and who really made
this day happen
I promise you all this is a bigger day
for them than it is you
you know when President Obama asked me
to be his vice president I said I only
had two conditions one I wouldn't wear
any funny hats even on class day and two
I wouldn't change my brand
I realize nor no one ever doubts I mean
what I say the problem occasionally as I
say all that I mean I have a bad
reputation for being straight sometimes
in an appropriate time so here goes
let's get a couple things straight right
off the bat Corvettes are better than
Porsches they're quicker in a corner as
well and sorry guys ah Capello is not
better than rock and roll and your
pundits are better than Washington
pundits although I've noticed neither
has any shame at all and all roads lead
to toads
you ever tried it on Monday night look
you know it's tough to end a great men's
basketball in football season one
touchdown away from beating Harvard this
year for the first time since 2006 so
close to something you won it for eight
years I can only imagine how you feel I
can only imagine so close so close
but I gotta be honest we did when the
invitation came I was flattered but it
caused a little bit of a problem in my
extended family it forced me to face
some hard truths my son Beau Biden the
Attorney General of Delaware and my
daughter Ashley Biden runs a non-profit
for criminal justice in the state they
both went to Penn my two nieces
graduated from Harvard won an
all-american all of them all of them
think my being here was a very bad idea
another saying my son Hunter who heads
the World Food Program USA graduated
from Yale Law School hey he thought it's
a great idea
but then again law graduates always
think all their ideas are great ideas by
the way I've had a lot of law graduates
from Yale work for me that's not too far
from the truth but anyway look the truth
of the matter is that I have a lot of
staff that are Yale graduates several of
with me today they thought it was a
great idea that I speak here as a matter
of fact my former national security
adviser Jake Sullivan who's teaching
here at Yale Law School trained in
international relations at Yale College
edited the Yale Daily News and graduated
from Harvard Law Firm so excuse me
Freudian slip Yale Law School you're
lucky to have him
he's brilliant and decent an honorable
man and I miss him and we miss him as my
national security adviser but he's not
the only one my deputy national security
adviser Jeff Prescott started and ran
the China Law Center at Yale Law School
my middle east policy advisor and
foreign policy speech writer dan bananas
with me took daily themes got to be
now you know why I go off-script so much
look at a gridiron turner not long ago
the president said I the president I am
learning to speak without a proper
teleprompter Joe's learning to speak
with one but if you looked at my speech
writers you know why I moved and the
granddaughter of one of my dearest
friends in life a former Holocaust
survivor a former foreign policy adviser
a former chairman of the House Committee
and foreign affairs congressman Tim Tom
Lantos is graduated today marina
congratulations kiddo where are you
you are the sixth she's the sixth
sibling and her immediate family to
graduate from Yale six out of eleven
that's not a bad batting average I
believe it's a modern-day record for the
number of kids who went to Yale from a
single family and mercy no I know your
mom little Annette is here I don't know
where you are a net but a net was part
of the first class of freshmen women
admitted to Yale University
then a grandmother and that is also a
Holocaust survivor an amazing woman and
both I'm sure wherever they are beaming
today and I know one thing more Massena
you're your father and grandfather
looking down cheering you on I'm so
happy to be here on your day and all of
your days it's good to know there's one
Yalie
who was happy I'm being here and be here
at least one on overheard at Yale on the
Facebook page one student reported
another student saying and I quote I had
a dream that I was vice president and
was with the president and we did the
disco funk dance to convince Congress to
restart the government another student
coming it y'all know bite would be
hilarious get funky well my
granddaughter Finnegan Biden whose dad
went here is with me today when she saw
that on the speech I was in the plane
Air Force to come up she said pop it
take a lot more than you and the
president doing the disco funk dance the
tea party doesn't even know what it is
look I don't know about that but I'm
just glad there's someone just someone
who dreams of being vice president just
somebody
I never had that dream
and for the press out there that's a
joke actually being vice president to
Barack Obama has been truly a great
honor we both enjoy getting out of the
White House to talk to folks in the real
America the kind who know what it means
to struggle to work hard to shop at Kiko
Milano
great choice I just hope the hell the
same folks responsible for Keiko's
aren't in charge of naming the two new
residential colleges now look folks I
spent a lot of time thinking about what
I should say to you today but the more I
thought about it I thought that any
class day speech is likely to be
redundant you already heard from Jessie
J at Spring Fling so what the hell could
I possibly say look I'm deeply honored
that Jeremy and Kiki selected me I don't
know how the hell you trusted them to do
that I hope you agree or their choice
actually I hope by the end of the speech
they agree with their choice in their
flattering invitation letter they asked
me to bring along a sense of humor speak
about my commitment to public service
and family talk about resiliency
compassion and leadership in a changing
world pretty tall order I probably
already flunked the first part of the
test but with the rest let me say up
front and I mean this sincerely there's
nothing particularly unique about me
with regard to resilience and compassion
there are countless thousands of people
maybe some in the audience who'd suffer
through personal losses similar to mine
are much worse with much less support to
help them get through it and much less
reason to want to get through it it's
not all that difficult folks to be
compassionate when you've been the
beneficiary of compassion in your lowest
moments not only from your family but
from your friends in total strangers
because when you know how much it meant
to you you know how much it mattered
it's not hard to be compassionate I was
raised by a tough compassionate Irish
lady earn a lady named Catherine Eugenia
Finnegan Biden
she taught all our children that but for
the grace of God there go you but for
the grace of God there go you and a
father who lived his motto that family
was the beginning the middle and the end
who like many of you and your parents I
was fortunate I learned early on what I
wanted to do what fulfilled me the most
what made me happy my family my faith
and being engaged in the public affairs
that gripped my generation and being
inspired by a young president named
Kennedy civil rights the environment
trying to end an incredibly useless and
divisive war Vietnam the truth is though
that neither I nor anyone else can tell
you what will make you happy
help you find success you each have
different comfort levels everyone has
different goals and aspirations but one
thing I've observed one thing I know the
expression my dad would use often is
real he used to say it's a lucky man or
woman gets up in the morning and I mean
this sincerely was one of his
expressions so lucky man a woman gets up
in the morning puts both feet on the
floor knows what they're about to do and
thinks it still matters I've been lucky
and I wish for all of you is a not only
tomorrow but 20 and 40 and 50 years from
now you found that sweet spot the thing
that allows you to get up in the morning
put both feet in the floor go out and
pursue what you love and think it still
matters some of you will go to Silicon
Valley and make eight great
contributions to empower individuals and
societies and maybe even design a life
changing app like how to unsubscribe to
Obama for America email list the biggest
pain list of all times some of you go to
Wall Street and big Wall Street law
firms government and activism Peace
Corps Teach for America you become
doctors researchers journalists artists
actors musicians two of you one of whom
was one of my former interns of the
White House Sean Cohen and Andrew Heyman
will be commissioned in the United
States Navy congratulations gentlemen
we're proud of you
but all of you have one thing in common
you all seek to find that sweet spot to
satisfy your ambition and success and
happiness I've met an awful lot of
people in my career and I've noticed one
thing those who are the most successful
and the happiness whether they're
working on Wall Street or Main Street as
a doctor or a nurse or as a lawyer or
social worker
I've made certain basic observations
about the ones who from my observation
wherever they were in the world were
able to find that sweet spot between
success and happiness
those who balance life and career who
find purpose and fulfillment and where
the ambition leads them there's no
silver bullet no single formula no
reductive list but they all seem to
understand that happiness and success
result from an accumulation of thousands
of little things built on character all
of which have certain common features in
my observation first the most successful
happiest people I've known understand
that a good life at its core is about
being personal
it's about being engaged it's about
being there for a friend or a colleague
when they're injured or in an accident
remembering the birthdays congratulating
them on their marriage celebrating the
birth of the child
it's about being available to them when
they're going through personal loss it's
about loving someone more than yourself
as one of your speakers have already
mentioned it all seems to get down to
being personal that's the stuff that
fosters relationships it's the only way
to breed trust and everything you do in
your life let me give you an example
after only four months in the United
States Senate as a 30 year old kid I was
walking through the Senate floor to go
to a meeting with Majority Leader Mike
Mansfield and I witnessed another newly
elected senator the extremely
conservative Jesse Helms excoriating Ted
Kennedy and Bob Dole for promoting the
precursor of the Americans with
Disabilities Act but I had to see the
leader so I kept walking
when I walked into Mansfield's office I
must have looked as angry as I was he
was in his late 70s lived to be a
hundred and he looked at me he said
what's bothering you Joe I said that guy
Helms he has no social redeeming value
he doesn't care I really mean it I was
angry he doesn't care about people in
need
he's a disregard for the disabled
majority and a man Phil then proceeded
to tell me that three years earlier
Jesse and dot Helms sitting in their
living room in early December before
Christmas
reading an ad
and the Raleigh Observer the picture of
a young man 14 years old with braces on
his legs up to both hips saying all I
want is someone to love me and adopt me
he looked at me and he said and they
adopted him Joe I felt like a fool he
then went on to say Joe it's always
appropriate to question another man's
judgment but never appropriate to
question his motives because you simply
don't know his motives it happened early
in my career fortunately from that
moment on I tried to look back to
character past the caricatures of my
colleagues and try to see the whole
person never once have I questioned
another man's or woman's motive and
something started to change if you
notice every time there's a crisis in
the Congress the last eight years I get
sent to the hill to deal with it it's
because every one of those men and women
up there whether they like me or not
know that I don't judge them for it I
think they're thinking because when you
question a man's motive when you say
they're acting out of greed they're in
the pocket of an interest group etc it's
awful hard to reach consensus it's awful
hard never to reach across the table and
shake hands no matter how bitterly you
disagree though it is always possible if
you question judgment and not motive
senator Helms and I continue to have
profound political differences but early
on we both became the most powerful
members of the Senate running the
Foreign Relations Committee he's
chairman and ranking members but
something happened the mutual defensive
miss began to dissipate and as a result
we began to be able to work together in
the interest of the country and as
chairman and ranking member we pass some
most significant legislation passed in
the last 40 years all of which he
opposed from paying tens of millions of
dollars in a rare gist to an institution
he despised the United Nations he was
part of the so-called black helicopter
crowd to passing the chemical weapons
treaty constantly referring to we've
never lost a war and we've never won a
treaty which he vehemently opposed but
we're able to do these things not
because he changed his mind but because
in this new relationship to maintain it
is required to play fair to be straight
the cheap shots ended and the chicane
are' to keep from having to being able
to vote ended even though he knew I had
the votes after that we went on as he
began to look at the other side of
things and do some great things together
that he supported like PEPFAR
which by the way george w bush deserves
another whelming amount of credit for by
the way
which provided treatment and prevention
hiv/aids in Africa and around the world
literally saving millions of lives so
one piece of advice is try to look
beyond the caricature of the person with
whom you have to work resist the
temptation to ascribe motive because you
really don't know and it gets in the way
of being able to reach a consensus on
things that matter to you and to many
other people resist the temptation of
your generation to let Network become a
verb but that saps the personal away
that blinds you to the person right in
front of you blind you to their hopes
their fears and their burdens build real
relationships even with people with whom
you've Bement ly disagree you'll not
only be happier you will be more
successful
the second thing I've noticed is that
although you know no one is better than
you every other person is equal to you
and deserves to be treated with dignity
and respect I've worked with eight
presidents hundreds of senators I've met
every major world leader literally in
the last 40 years and I've had scores of
talented people work for me and here's
what I observe regardless of their
academic or social backgrounds those who
had the most success and that were most
respected and therefore able to get the
most done were the ones who never
confused
academic credentials and societal
sophistication with gravitas and
judgment don't forget about what doesn't
come from this prestigious diploma the
heart to know what's meaningful and
what's ephemeral and the head to know
the difference between knowledge and
judgment but even you get these things
right I've observed most people who are
successful and happy remember the third
thing reality has a way of intruding I
got elected in a very improbable year
Richard Nixon won my state
overwhelmingly George McGovern was at
the top of the ticket I got elected as a
Sanka the second youngest man in the
history of the United States to be
elected the stuff that provides and
fuels raw ambition if you're not careful
it fuels a sense of inevitability that
seeps in but be careful
things can change in a heartbeat I know
and so do many of your parents six week
after my election my whole my whole
world was altered forever while I was in
Washington hiring staff I got a phone
call my wife and three children were
Christmas shopping tractor-trailer
broadsided and killed my wife and killed
my daughter and they weren't sure that
my sons would live
many people have gone through things
like that but because I had the
incredible good fortune of an extended
family grounded in love and loyalty
imbued with a sense of obligation
imparted to each of us I not only got
help but by focusing on my sons I found
my redemption I can remember my mother
sweet lady
looking at me after we left the hospital
in Saint Joe II out of everything
terrible that happens to you something
good will come if you look hard enough
for it
she was right incredible bond I have
with my children as a gift I'm not sure
I would have had had I not been through
what I went through who knows whether I
would have been able to appreciate at
that moment in my life that heady moment
in my life what my first obligation was
so I began to commute never intending to
stay in Washington and that's the God's
truth I was supposed to be sworn in with
everyone else that year in 73 but I
wouldn't go down so Mansfield thought
I'd change my mind and not come he sent
up Secretary of Senate to swear me in in
the hospital room with my children and I
began to commute thinking I was only
gonna stay a little while four hours a
day every day from Washington and
Wilmington which I've done for over 37
years I did it because I want to be able
to kiss them goodnight and kiss them in
the morning the next day no Ozzie and
Harriet breakfast there
great familial thing just climb in bed
with him
because it came I came to realize that
the child couldn't hold an important
thought something they want to say to
their mom and dad maybe for 12 or 24
hours and then it's gone and when it's
gone it's gone and it all adds up but
looking back on it the truth be told the
real reason I went home every night was
that I needed my children more than they
needed me some at the time wrote and
suggest that the Biden can't be a
serious national figure if he was he'd
stay in Washington more attend the more
important events it's obvious he's not
serious he goes home after the last vote
but I realized I didn't miss a thing
ambition is really important you need it
and I certainly have never lacked in
having ambition but ambition without
perspective can be a killer I know a lot
of you already understand this some of
you really had to struggle to get here
and some of you had to struggle to stay
here and some of your families made
enormous sacrifices for this great
privilege and many of you create your
own crisis someone imaginable but the
truth is all of you will go through
something like this you'll wrestle with
these kinds of choices every day but I'm
here to tell you can find the balance
between ambition and happiness what will
make you really feel fulfilled and along
the way it helps a great deal if you can
resist the temptation to rationalize my
chief of staff for over 25 years when
the finest men I've ever known
even though he graduated from Penn and
subsequently became a senator from the
state of Delaware
senator Ted Kaufman every new hire that
we'd hire the last thing he tell them
was and remember never underestimate the
ability of the human mind to rationalize
never underestimate the ability of human
mind to rationalize her birthday really
doesn't matter that much to her and this
business trip is just a great
opportunity this won't be his last game
and besides I'd have to take the red-eye
to get back we can always take this
family vacation another time there's
plenty of time for your generation
there's an incredible amount of pressure
on all of you to succeed particularly
now that you've accomplished so much
your whole generation faces this
pressure I see to my grandchildren who
are honors students at other Ivy
universities right now you race to do
what other thinks think is right in high
school you raced to the bloodsport of
college admissions you raced through
Yale for the next big thing and all
along some of you compared yourself to
the success of your peers on Facebook
Instagram likened in Twitter today some
of you may have found that you slipped
into that self referential bubble that
validates certain choices and the bubble
expands once you leave this campus the
pressures and the anxiousness as well
take this job make that much money live
in this place
hang out with people like you take no
real risks and have no real impact while
getting paid for the false sense of both
but resist that temptation of
rationalize what others view is the
right choice for you instead of what you
feel in your gut is the right choice for
you
that's your North Star trust him
follow it you're an incredible group of
young women young women and men and
that's not hyperbole you're an
incredible group let me conclude with
this I'm not gonna moralize about to
whom much is given much is expected
because most of you have made of
yourself much more than what you've been
given but now you are in a privileged
position you're part of an exceptional
generation and doors will open to you
that will not open to others
my Yale Law School grad son graduated
very well from Yale Law School
whether sown out of loyalty to his
deceased mother decided to go to
Syracuse law school from Penn there a
year in a day apart in their age come on
a graduate from Yale had doors open to
him the lowest salary offered back in
the early 90s was fifty thousand dollars
more than a federal judge made my other
son it was a struggle equally as bright
went on to be elected one of the
youngest Attorney General's in the
history of the state of Delaware most
popular public official in my state big
headline after the 2012 election Biden
most popular man in Delaware - beau
as your parents will understand my dad's
definition of success is when you look
at your son and daughter and realize
they turned out better than you and they
did but you'll have opportunities make
the most of them and follow your heart
you have the intellectual horsepower to
make things better in the world around
you
you're also part of the most tolerant
generation in history
I got roundly criticized because I could
not remain quiet anymore about gay
marriage the one thing I was certain of
is all of your generation but way beyond
that point
here's something else I observed
intellectual horsepower and tolerance
alone does not make a generation great
unless you can break out of the bubble
of your own making
technological geographically racially
socially economically to truly connect
with the world around you because it
matters no matter what your material
success or personal circumstance it
matters you can't breathe fresh air or
protect your children from a changing
climate no matter what you make if your
sister is the victim of domestic
violence
you are violated if your brother McCain
marry the man he loves you are lessened
and if your best friend has to worry
about being racially profiled you live
in a circumstance not worthy of us it
mattered
so be successful I sincerely hope some
of you become millionaires and
billionaires I mean that but engage the
world around you because you will be
more successful and happier and you can
absolutely succeed in life without
sacrificing your ideals your commitments
to others and your family I'm confident
that you can do that I'm confident that
this generation will do it more than any
other so look to your left as they say
look to your right and remember how
foolish the people next to you look in
those ridiculous hats that's what I want
you to remember I mean this because it
means you've learned something from a
great tradition it means you're willing
to look foolish you're willing to run
the risk of looking foolish in the
service of what matters to you and if
you remember that because some of the
things your heart will tell you to do
we'll make you among your peers look
foolish or not smart or not
sophisticated but we'll all be better
off for people of your consequence to do
it
that's what I want you to most remember
not who spoke at the day you all
assembled on this mall you're remarkable
class I sure don't he'll remember who
that was my commencement speaker
I know this is not officially
commencement but ask your parents when
you leave here who spoke at your
commencement it's a it's a commencement
speaker a version of a commencement
seekers fate to be forgotten the
question is only how quickly but you're
the best in your generation and that is
not hyperbole and you're part of a
remarkable generation and you you're on
the cusp of some of the most astonishing
breakthroughs in the history of mankind
scientific technological system socially
that's gonna change the way we live in
the whole world works
it'll be up to you in this changing
world to translate those unprecedented
capabilities into a greater measure of
happiness and meaning not just for
yourself for the world around you and I
feel more confident from my children and
grandchildren knowing that the men and
women who graduate here today here and
across the country will be in their
midst that's the honest truth that's the
God's truth that's my word as a Biden
congratulations class of 2015 and may
God bless you and may God protect our
troops thank you
you